PREDATORS.
THE SECOND UNIT. THE E  I CAN S
GREENE, HE IS MOVING UP BUT REA
CHANCES.
SO THEY ARE NOT JUST OUT THERE
TO CRASH AND BANG.
THEY ARE CONTROLLING THE PLAY.
EXECUTION AND OFFENSIVE
MOVED IT OUT
TO DOBSON.
A PASS FOR
ONCE IT WAS READY HE THE SEVENT
BEST  IT'S HIGH.
HE IS WAITING A DOWN.
IT GOES BACK TO KYLELE
LEE.
MAYFIELD, SHOT TO TO
SHORT-CIRCUIT THE PLAY.
OFF DEFENDER.
BUT THE DELAYED PENALTY CALL  T
YAKOV TRENIN GOES FROM  NOT !
>> YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT ABOUT
TANNER JEANNOT . IF THAT WENTBA
JUUSE SAROS.  LOOSE, AND THAT I
GREAT SAVE.
MATT DUCHENE IS IT.
NELSON IS PRESSURED ALONG THE
BOARDS.
THAT GOES TO THE FAR SIDE, SARO
GETS THE DEFLECTION  WORK.
WE HAVE RYAN JO
GRANLUND.
JOSH BAILEY DOES NOT LIKE WHAT
HE SEES.
HE WILL THE ROOKIE.
NO ANGLE TO
SHOOT.
WE HAVE 45 SECOND
THEY COULD TO GET MATHEW BARZAL
FROM WINNING AT GAME ON THE  TO
HE TRIES TO BEAT HIM OVER THE
BLOCKER.
JUUSE SAROS BY FILIP FORSBERG.
THAT Chris: